It's the final domino in the series
because the entire sexual spectrum of
everybody's whatever they're into all of
the Kinks this is the hardest one if we
can unravel this one all the others are
simpler less fraught version of this
toughest
your research area
paraphilia and Associated phenomena
what is paraphilia
uh
well I studied what makes anybody into
whatever it is that they're into uh when
when I started the big question wasn't
including for myself uh what made me gay
what makes a gay person gay you know I I
started with the same curiosity that uh
uh that we all did uh I just kind of
tripped over the course of my career to
an opportunity to start asking the
bigger version of that question never
mind gay what makes you know all of the
others how does the brain know what to
be attracted to or not to be attracted
to
uh and so that then led me to what uh to
the paraphilias themselves which are
sexual interest patterns but not just
preferences not blonde versus brunette
or top versus bottom I mean people who
are it's meaningful to call these uh
sexual orientations unto themselves they
show uh these are interest patterns like
exhibitionists pedophiles uh uh
tuturists some kinds of cross-dressers
when they when they funded sexual
arousing these are profound profound
sexual interest patterns that these
people have and as I say it seems to
show every uh every sign of being innate
and immutable
so what's up with that
so the paraphilias you know we still
debate over you know does this one count
does that one uh count but the general
idea are these other other than sexual
orientation other than male versus
female all of the other atypical uh
sexual interest patterns the the really
really built-in practically born with a
kind of Interest patterns so that that I
guess is my non-technical uh uh my
non-technical definition of it allowing
room for we don't exactly know where the
boundaries are what about asexuality the
least sexual of the sexual paraphilias
yep uh
there's no good simple answer I don't
think it's an it uh the term is a bit of
a catch-all uh people these days
especially are kind of mixing up medical
language you know when a medical
diagnosis where we've identified the
cause of something with psychiatric
diagnosis which doesn't identify the
cause Psychiatry is different from other
branches of medicine in Psychiatry they
label the symptoms
you know we just called the symptom
depression or sadness depression but
whether it's caused by one thing or
another that doesn't matter you get the
same same diagnosis as I say so
Psychiatry is unlike the rest of
medicine and that it labels just the
symptoms
so for the paraphilias uh and the others
that's as I say kind of an open question
exactly where the line goes when do we
diagnose it when do we not is it in the
uh is it in the person's favor
uh so it's not as I say it's not such a
simple uh question so for asexuals well
it's not posing a problem for anyone
else and there can be way more than one
thing leading a person to think that
that label kind of kind of fits them now
it could be somebody just with a low sex
drive
you know but low sex drive is not
pardoned upon very sexy label for it but
asexual is something that
it's a label they can use all of a
sudden they have a support group and
people
uh the important part the part that's
very easy to be empathetic for is that
it socially it tells people how to
interact with them you know don't start
introducing them to potential you know
Partners you know that they're not going
to be interested and don't take it
personally so it serves a can serve a
certain legitimate uh social function
flip side there were just regular
everyday people with regular everyday
insecurities about you know whatever it
is about their sexual life and rather
than risk projection rather than play at
that game and risk losing they adopt the
label asexual just to get out of the
whole thing you know that's not such a
healthy reason you know if I had such a
person in therapy it'd be reasonable to
help the person get over their their
insecurities or for some people
especially on the autism uh Spectrum
there are people who have you know
social skill deficits and it's really
social skills training that would lead
to more self-confidence and so they
don't need a label uh of asexual
uh and then you know people just as they
get older and sex drive drops again will
adopt the term kind of as a euphemism
for uh for low sex drive uh so although
they kind of have in common uh a
signaling to the people around them you
know how to interact properly or how to
interact in a way that they want to be
interacted with uh we oughtn't or no
scientists should you know take it at
face value to me literally that the
person lacks a sex drive either a lot of
people can adopt the label for other
kinds of reasons
all of which is to say it's not like we
have proof that it doesn't exist either
I mean if it could be attracted to one
pattern attracted to another pattern I
can imagine attracted to neither
but the last one and again because of
the very strange seat that uh that I get
to sit in the other one is that
somebody's attracted to something
unusual that they don't want to cop to
you know it could be something really
really problematic like they're
attracted to children or they're just
attracted to something that right in the
particular audience or in front of their
family or for whatever reasons they
don't want to be out with it it's not
something that they're going to be
sharing with anybody outside for example
outside of their fetish community so
again they will adopt the label asexual
to kind of cover for their real uh for
the real story or people don't want to
you know admit to themselves what it is
that they're into so again they give
themselves a reason to not be into
anything you blew my mind when you
mentioned talking about why this seemed
to be more child offenses coming out of
the Catholic church and Priests that the
priesthood a place where you are like
you take a vow of celibacy you are
tending to be away from most of the
people this is a life of service this is
a life of virtue that would be the kind
of place that someone who is trying to
potentially in some circumstances hide
from a sexuality that they're a little
bit concerned about might Retreat to I
thought oh wow that is such an
interesting way to look at why there has
been this preponderance in there and it
plays into that as well going on to the
autism conversation I'm pretty sure that
a bunch of very famous inventors
throughout history Isaac Newton I'm
pretty sure went through his entire life
and remained a virgin there may have
been some uh religious sort of overtones
over that but how much he was using the
religiosity as a cope the Justified
something that was coming out of him
that he perhaps didn't want to uh face
um but yeah two really interesting
parallels that I've seen there figures
from history High performing
philosophers a ton of them engineers
physicists that didn't want to face
anything sexual is that a byproduct is
that a cope are they hiding and then the
priesthood as well two really
interesting examples
yeah uh the uh the priesthood's a funny
one and uh you know there's no good way
to study it in any objective way there's
just so much politics pulling in uh in
every direction uh but that some people
use it as they got uh as a retreat you
know so so my family stops asking me you
know how come I'm not married to a woman
you know it's uh
but not only for pedophiles for uh but
also regular everyday gay men who don't
want to deal with being gay or you know
less now today than prior generations of
course but same thing it was uh it was
an escape into uh in that context
socially acceptable or socially more
acceptable way to still circulate in
society be productive in its way uh but
not have to
uh lived it's living a hidden life I
don't want to say in plain sight exactly
and for some people they're denying the
truth of it to themselves as much as
denying it to the uh to the world around
them uh so for you know the gays when
you know the ones who do eventually come
out anyway the pedophiles for whom we
find out the hard way but anybody with
any real atypical sexuality again it
provides the same kind of
Escape or cover a cover story I think is
the best is the best term what's the
best explanation that we've got for why
male homosexuality exists in humans at
all oh
this was one of the things that that
really first got me into uh into this
main uh main question I didn't do very
much research in it directly I I played
a supporting role to uh uh to Ray
Blanchard I I was I was his Mini Me and
he was already well on the way of uh
unraveling uh unraveling that one
another just fascinating story and I
just had a background in the brain by
sheer accident ended up doing my
internship you know at a gender clinic
but it had Ray Blanchard in it it was
one of the chief you know scientists
pursuing exactly that question he was
looking at brain development I had a
background in the brain and so just
foreign
he identified that led to the unraveling
uh is called the older brother effect
pure unremarkable you wouldn't notice it
to the naked eye except an
epidemiologist studying the data
the more male fetuses a woman has the
more Sons she gives birth to the more
likely the latter-born kids males are to
be gay that is gay men on average have
more older brothers than they should
it's the older brother effect
and it's one of those
How could a fetus how could the
development of the brain what how could
a fetus know how many fetuses came
before it it was a very but consistent
no matter what what time era that
Blanchard could find a a data set from
no matter what country no matter in what
context the older brother effect was was
there very strange
eventually what he was able to figure
out is that uh if you remember you know
why fetuses at Wifey this is uh male
fetuses and only male fetuses carry a y
chromosome
Which is far into the mother's system
she's formed of two X chromosomes
so far as her body is concerned a y
chromosome is a foreign material for
which your immune system starts to react
so with every passing male fetus is more
exposure to
they've called if they have a long
technical name the Hy histocompatibility
antigens
the substances right that the mother's
body produces to neutralize the proteins
that are coming off the Y chromosome
which is supposed to be masculinizing
the fetus
so sometimes those anti-mail
the immune system reactions seem to hold
back some of the masculinization of the
male and only the male fetuses and it
happens you know with every exposure
even to fetuses that were in her body
but she never carried to term aborted
fetuses or uh miscarriages
still in the order they they should be
in
so that's why it runs in families a
little bit but not because homosexuality
is inherited
but the maternal immune response is
that is wild even though it goes through
the women of the family even though the
homosexuality only functions in the
males in the family
so do you as a daughter of a mother that
had lots of sons
does the daughter retain that knowledge
somehow
not in a direct way that anybody's been
able to fact uh find uh the best as I
said the best connection is that you
know her immune system is related to uh
to her mother's system and there are
large transfers of material between
maternal system and fetus which is a
fascinating fascinating a branch of uh
of biology to itself uh but nobody's
found that in that transfer of material
and the mother preparing the fetus for
its own immune environment nobody's
found that the Hy histocompatibility
antigens go uh goes through it why do
you think that this would be adaptive
why would this be around
that's a good question it could be a
side effect it's easy to imagine that as
I say it's just a side effect of
something powerful about the immune
system and so you know it's worth
sacrificing you know however many
potential grandchildren if the gay ones
are less likely to reproduce that the
gains from whatever this difference in
the immune system offsets the decrease
in reproducibility later it's a to
Evolution it's a math game okay so if
that's male homosexuality what about
lesbians
it women are always a more complicated
when it comes to social stuff
for men
I'm grossly exaggerating for men you
know
sex is a drive like hunger there's not a
lot we can do about it
for women again I'm overstated a bit
it's more of a mood
it doesn't have quite the same drive
it's awfully dependent on stress and
context expectations for the future all
bound into one great big ball where for
men it's kind of hot not you know sex
with our worst enemy if they're hot
enough piece of cake for women that's
just that's a much more unusual as I say
for women it's more of it's more like a
mood
uh so there are stuff that so there does
seem to be a biological component and it
does seem to be that uh their brains are
shifted in a more masculine Direction
but there are many uh more women than
men who will refer to
contextual Parts relational Parts
memories of old relationships or prior
abusive relationships they refer to that
you know much much more is contributing
but and it's unclear is that really
contributing to their sexual orientation
the way that men think of theirs hours
or is that just those memories interfere
with how easy it is to get into one mood
versus another yes so when when Comfort
amongst females is such an important
part of sex and arousal something which
has predisposed you to feel comfortable
may become a part of your sexuality
because that Comfort is so intrinsically
linked I had a conversation yesterday at
lunch with a friend and he has a girl
friend who her first sexual encounter
was with one of her female friends when
she was in her teens or whatever they
felt comfortable they felt safe and she
has now rolled forward into a marriage
where she still feels [ __ ] the
apparently the
the husband has absolutely no fears at
all that she's ever going to cheat on
him with a man but he does sometimes
wonder about what she gets up to when
she goes out to on holiday or to Hindus
and stuff like that and she's like
they're in it sort of semi-open thing in
any case but
what she says is
there is something about that degree of
comfort that has sort of stayed with her
and given that that was her formative or
one of her formative first-time
experiences it does seem like that's
left a kind of imprint here's another
one for you and I don't know whether
you've ever come across this so I have a
friend who is bisexual but heavily
lesbian so she mostly sleeps with women
and sometimes sleeps with men
we were talking about birth control and
she said that she'd come off birth
control I asked her what had happened
and she said oh my sex drive went
through the roof and a bunch of other
things uh one other interesting thing
that I found was that during my
ovulation period I had a big change in
sex drive I was like okay that's
interesting well what happened he says
well I'm gay for three weeks out of
every month but for one week out of
every month I turned straight again
have you ever come across this yeah dude
that blew my mind I had to put my fault
down I was like oh my God this is so
interesting yeah there's as I say women
are you know and fascinated that way
complicated and there are different
we have one itch they have different
they have several itches and different
itches need stretching in different ways
uh also changes uh for women according
to mood or across their uh their Cycles
uh dumb sub stuff
that sometimes they'll be you know in a
kinky aggressive kind of mood or in a
kinky Super Sub mood and with other
people or in other situations or they'll
be done with Med sub with women it's
there's just this cluster and as I say
and they will have a couple of different
ways to
roads to Rome yes that's not it what is
it whatever yeah
I learned about Red Deer Scottish Red
Deer and the fact that when the females
come into heat the males start deploying
tons of testosterone and they go from
being really docile and friendly with
all of their male counterparts to these
having these huge antlers and trying to
kill all of the other men that they were
recently friends with and have been
chilling with for the last nine months
then they go create a harem super
aggressive and then the women stop being
in heat and then everything goes back to
normal again given the fact that the
behavior of those animals changes so
much due to the Cascade of hormones it
makes complete sense that small
relatively small changes in women would
happen when their profile of hormones
changes it just happens to be more
consistent than once every year
ah
yes all perfectly logical or perfectly
plausible although you know we're at the
far reaches of my uh
my real expertise uh I've often found it
less useful to think about you know
hormones having this you know kind of
whatever effect and therefore should
have whatever analogous effect you know
across species uh and more
how would this have helped Evolution or
against it it's uh you know because and
then the hormones and what increases or
decreases whatever behaviors of hours
changes species to species in order for
us to fit in whatever our you know
evolutionary network is so again in that
species right the offset of killing off
some of the other males must have an
evolutionary benefit that offsets that
and again this is the animal husbandry
is uh is not my thing right so there's
got to be some Niche that it fits for
them that didn't work for us you know
that didn't work for us as we came down
from the trees but what that might be I
I guess I just uh hesitate to uh make
all animals analogous to all other
animals you know disembedded from The
evolutionary pressures that got us there
getting onto some more murky territory
what do you think most people
misunderstand when it comes to
pedophilia oh uh same as when I got into
uh into the field uh that people confuse
pedophilia for a synonym for child
molestation
uh because people uh conversations are
only about the behavior people have
trouble
separating that from the sexual
attraction pattern uh again for any
listeners who haven't heard it before uh
pedophilia is the sexual attraction
pattern itself these are people who are
genuinely sexually attracted to Children
the way the rest of us are uh to adults
but doesn't mean they ever did anyone
you know it doesn't mean they committed
any crime or hurt anyone they they just
have the sexual attraction pattern you
know first to their own peers when
they're young but as they mature they
continue to be attracted to whatever age
uh that was where the rest of us you
know develop attracted attractions to
adults uh and vice versa isn't
one-to-one either the people who commit
the offenses the actual child molesters
are usually not pedophiles uh incest
Defenders for example are usually not
into kids they're using the kid as as a
as a surrogate and they prefer adults
but don't have access to an adult
roughly about a third as I say of
offenders against children are genuinely
uh or Genuine pedophiles uh not so for
uh for child porn the people who are
collecting child porn are genuinely into
kids even though they rarely would have
ever touched a kid their their offenses
that you know indirect kind of offense
you know where the victim is that the
the unconsenting uh uh subject of the
picture
uh so the biggest misunderstanding is
that you know a pedophile is not a
criminal before he committed an offense
he was an innocent person and that's the
day we need to get to him
these are people who are usually
struggling with it they know something's
wrong and we want them to be able to
come in for therapy sex drive reducing
medications you know whatever it will
take to help this person you know stay
Crime Free
uh unfortunately because people
automatically associate oh this is a
criminal waiting to happen they end up
you know bringing all of the stigma and
all of the condemnation
which really just drives them
underground so instead of having them
you know in therapy getting whatever
they need they're all alone and
desperate
which is crazy to me you know that's
just that's making the problem worse
uh so that's a very long answer but the
biggest misunderstanding as I say is
that people have because people only
hear about Peter Philly in the context
of molestation people you know have
trouble seeing that these are
overlapping but non-identical categories
well there's such a visceral response to
those stories right and they do get a
good bit of press coverage when it comes
out
and I suppose what would be newsworthy
about here is a non-offending pedophile
who sits quietly in his house like why
is that going to make headlines no one's
writing an article about that really
unless it was a very interesting expose
that said there is this group of people
out there that are worthy of
sympathy because of the sort of
difficulty that they have to go through
to keep their type of sexuality under
control in terms of enacting it uh so
when it comes to what causes pedophilia
to arise how much biological
environmental influences going on here
and and why does that happen
uh we have really solid evidence for the
biological contributions but no solid
evidence for learned kinds of influences
I mean we can't rule it out I mean we
can never you know in science
permanently rule anything out it's
always possible for you know future
evidence to say anything but so far we
have biology you know right down to
brain scans and clues leading to
developmental episodes that happened
before birth uh the biggest one is
handedness in regular everyday
populations you know somewhere between
eight to ten percent of people are are
non-right-handed so far as brain
organization is concerned and bidex
business goes together with
left-handedness
uh so it's about eight to ten percent of
the regular population but like 35
percent of the pedophiles
absolutely enormous
there's only one thing that makes
somebody non-right-handed you know and
outside of old Catholic schools they
didn't make you non-right-handed they
went the other way the only way that
that larger proportion of people are
non-right-handed is if something is
different about basic brain organization
and that the hemispheric dominance of
the brain is established by the end of
the first trimester that's what causes
handedness that's what causes handedness
and uh so a right-handed person is left
hemisphere dominant a left-handed person
and I'm very left-handed could go either
way uh it's roughly again about a third
of them it's cross Hemisphere and for
some it's just kind of 50 50. uh it's
just during early brain development at
one grows faster than the other but if
something happens during development
that gets in the way malnutrition of the
mothers stress or something the other
hemisphere then will try to catch up for
the lost time of the first one it takes
over some of the functions that the
original hemisphere would have had and
handedness is is one of them
so large differences in a population of
handedness again is a clue that
something maternal stress something
happened early in development and we're
just seeing one of these Echoes of uh
you know innocuous Behavior but it's
because it's pretty innocuous that we
can detect it pretty early in adulthood
but it still tells us something very
very important that was going on before
birth
so between the carbonation of the brain
scans showing us exactly where things
are different now and findings like
handedness and other Clues saying
whatever was different whatever length
of these chains eventually led to
pedophilia the first links were before
birth so when you put all of this
together it's as I said this is a
biological thing could there be things
learned in childhood sure but nobody's
come up with that kind of
Smoking Gun evidence where there's just
no other way to explain it
different for child molestation
childhood events stress crises tragedy
can lead during life during Young Life
can lead a prison to be disinhibited
you know impulsive unwilling you know
anti-social themselves I was hurt so
it's really not so bad if I do something
you know so a person who has an atypical
impulse
if they came from an abusive background
you know that kind of thing can be
learned but of course for pedophiles the
ones that we find out about are the ones
who committed crimes
who were more likely to have come from
an anti-social background you know so
that that so the association is stronger
because that's where you know that's the
area we get to see but there's there's
great big dark unknown never reported
and it's not like they're going to be
you know clicking yes on any internet
surveys anytime soon you know so there's
just no way
we know they exist but there's no way
for us to guess how many why would it be
the case the the mechanism that mediates
handedness would also play a role in
what somebody is attracted to in terms
of age and does that mean that there are
more gay people who are left-handed more
people into
sub Dom fetishes and stuff it does it
correlate with anything else
uh excellent question uh the first part
why would they be connected
they're not connected in any this leads
to this leads I wasn't accusing the
left-handed people of of being sexual
deviants no everybody always has to say
that and we also have to do the
homosexuality pedophilia distinction
exactly
uh
uh there's no direct link it's more uh
oh actually it's a great example uh you
remember that old and basically true
Chestnut you know correlation doesn't
mean causation
we recite that almost reflexively but
when nobody points out is well what does
it mean
there are three possibilities
when x correlates with y
X could be causing y
could be causing X
or the one everybody forgets there's a z
that causes both X and Y
so they come and go in frequency
together but there's no relationship
between them it's because they both come
from the same
so a lot of these correlates that people
talk about have that third variable
thing neither one is causing the other
even though that's always everybody's
gut reaction if they're trying to
endorse whatever Public public policy we
want more of this we want less of that
and so they start arguing for
connections where most of it is sorry
there is no connection it's because both
come from
this other thing
so the associations between hemispheric
dominance handedness and uh uh sexuality
appear to be one of those neither one
really is related to the other it's just
that if something unusual goes on during
brain development handedness is one of
the things that changes and sexual
interest pattern is one of the things
that changes but there's no
relationship between the two
that said
handedness is usually the first thing we
look at whenever we examine any new
sexual interest pattern that comes to
attention exactly because it does seem
to be different across the broad
spectrum of them it is higher in game
than straight men
not uh but not lesbians versus straight
women it is higher again in the
pedophiles versus the non-pedophiles and
it's higher in a couple of the other
paraphilias so again not that doesn't
mean any of these is related to any of
the others it's all that same Z it's all
that same something went different
during development and these are just
the many different sexual interest
patterns that can change and handedness
which can oh and hand in which can
change and one of the triggers of that
change is testosterone
in Utah
in utero again first mostly first
trimester uh mostly well that one's
really the end of the first trimester
and it's also why more men are
non-right-handed than women
because they are more heavily mediated
by testosterone
yep
and so the process to masculinize puts
the brain at risk for a couple of things
males are expandable they're Expendable
in a population if you lose pick a
number if you lose ten percent of men
there's more than enough sperm to go
around
but if you lose 10 of women you've lost
10 percent of the reproductive potential
so with that so all fetuses essentially
start female not in the way trans
activists like to say
uh but developmentally you know things
don't start shifting into the male
direction to the Y chromosome and
proteins don't kick in until a couple of
months in and sexual interest pattern is
one of the things that seems to change
so where
we would start with a relatively broad
mood pattern that women have
in order to bring that over so instead
of being attracted to men look for curvy
reproductive age
so we males have to go through that
process females don't we kind of start
our brains kind of start in that process
so that seems to be why so many more
males have these atypical sexualities
but women don't because that didn't have
to go through that process this is like
this is they are right-handedness where
for some of us we go through that
process the process isn't perfectly
debugged so we lose a couple of percent
to these atypical patterns
how much conscious control do people
have over what arouses them or what
they're sexually attracted to
this isn't acting on it this is what
arouses them
I want to say zero
I mean
we can distract ourselves if there's
something hot in the environment that we
don't want to be caught looking at or
you know in certain situations we don't
want to accidentally give ourselves an
erection and an inappropriate time or
place uh but that's not you know that
that's just
that's not changing or not being
interested in it it's avoiding the
avoiding or at least postponing the
stimulus very often that just became you
know masturbation meat for later that
night
uh but really there doesn't there
doesn't seem to be uh especially for men
we can be attracted to stuff despite
ourselves you know somebody other than
our monogamous partner somebody other
than whatever socially
approved stimulus you know that that
happens all the time but now we we can't
help if whatever your favorite flavor is
for me it's ice cream I can't will
myself not to like ice cream I might
have favorite flavors but
so when it comes to looking at
pedophiles there is
as far as you can see from your work
no conscious control over your ability
to decide what you're going to be
aroused by you do have conscious control
over whether you decide to act on that
and that's the line that you've drawn
between child molestation and pedophilia
but I mean this was something that I
learned about this girl that I was
dating at University
12 years ago or something was a doctor
and she said you know I I if I could
make one change to the way that the
World Views other people uh one of the
ones I think that would be interesting
to discuss would be that pedophiles need
more sympathy and my immediate response
is someone that was uninitiated was like
why how uh in the UK there's like a a
big deal about nonce radar about looking
out for to catch a predator and there's
a bunch of people like that yeah and I
was like after it doesn't take very much
thought to realize that if you're
someone that doesn't have conscious
control over what you're attracted to
and you're burned cursed with the
sexuality that the entire world is going
to condemn you for that you can't talk
to anybody else about and that you can't
act on
I mean that's that's a kind of living
hell it's hard to imagine a worse curse
I mean imagining you know again I grew
up you know gay in the 80s and 90s you
know and I'm just lucky not to have
grown up in the 50s now this you know
to makes that into a cakewalk
uh the whole conversation
seems like it's gotten harder to have
now
I've been having this conversation I've
been doing this kind of research for
we're going on 25 years
there was in its eccentric kind of way a
lot more tolerance
than than now there was a lot more in
media we didn't have social media uh yet
which is I think linked there was a oh
now I get it
and people immediately want the oh if
people didn't choose this then it was a
very simple step to well they didn't
choose anything and all we can ever do
with anyone is
find whatever proportions and Fantasies
according to what we can do either to
write down to
it's not possible to do some of these
either because it'll hurt somebody or
it's just not possible in physics and so
we find some fantasy way you know and
that's you know one rule one ethic one
and one principle to rule them all in it
so there was uh that was a story that
was possible
was possible uh
I'm I'm getting this award it hasn't
been officially presented to me yet I'm
getting this award distinguished
contribution from the association for
the treatment of sexual abusers
in no small part for having brought this
conversation uh uh to public light
but it's even though it was accepted
then several documentaries made about it
it's a harder conversation now because
that conversation takes
60 seconds of nuance for the oh now I
get it
that doesn't fit in a tweet
and nobody really wants the correct
answer even though everybody else is
saying you know that's actually how
we're going to defeat actual child
molestation or even if we find a way if
we can figure out what in the brain it
is maybe we can prevent it from
developing in the first place
right where everybody's like the answer
is actually there
but people are using social media just
for its version virtue signaling
I'm gonna show you what a child
protector I am and
they're making the situation worse by
driving underground the people we want
coming in and getting into therapy and
so on so because I find there's much
less honest conversation and social
media is just as I say The Virtue
signaling the messages are much harder
one to get out today than it was 25
years ago I have no idea where we're
going to go with it and it cuts across
political Spectrum it's not left or
right it's attention Seekers no matter
what motivation they have for the
attention both left and right they Pride
themselves on just how bad they can be
to the pedophiles
both sides making the problem worse I'm
gonna guess that the concern many people
have is that by opening up this
conversation and making it less taboo
you are somehow
giving a stamp of approval or at least
relinquishing a stamp of disapproval in
in some form or another
misunderstanding about the difference
between non-offending and an offending
pedophile and that as soon as you don't
condemn it in the worst possible way
with the most vehemently that you can
that's the same as being complicit or
supporting or that's that's the story
they give
I'm a little more cynical a little too
cynical to accept that on face value
again because basic humans haven't
changed Now versus 25 years ago what has
changed is now when they say it they're
saying it in front of the entire
universe
they genuinely I don't think the genuine
fear
is if we don't condemn it it's they're
going to feel free to do whatever they
want it's that if I don't condemn it I'm
not gonna look good
um it's an opportunity to stand on the
show virtue's signaling exactly it's
nobody you know accepts this idiot is
gonna say hang on a second you're
actually
making it worse
right there are very few people sending
into place to be able to say you know
they're only a handful of experts and
we're the ones who can say actually
treating them like human beings is
what's going to cause is what prevention
is going to come from if you give
somebody nothing to lose they're going
to act like somebody with nothing to
lose yes yeah I had a conversation with
Andrew gold and he went to the German
like German group uh the prevention
project Uncle Feld yes uh and there's
three risk characteristics I think the
first one is being around children the
second one is being inebriated and the
third one is feeling rebuffed from
society like you have no one to turn to
I'm like well you know it's a personal
choice to control the first two although
you could environmentally assist I
suppose by stopping them from going to
an off license or a children's pool but
the third one is almost exclusively done
by Society to the offenders and yeah I I
mean that's a to say that your response
to this conversation
is potentially causing greater
externalities to the exact group that
you're supposed to be trying to defend
and protect
is a like it's a difficult point to get
across right it's the same reason a
similar sort of reason to you're much
nicer than I am I'd look it was possible
to get the point across 25 years ago
the difference now is so much of a
conversation is people who don't care
what the point is they just want to look
like they are you know whatever hero
badge protecting children
doing the research and the work that now
for them have perfect confidence in
their gut reaction here's an interesting
thing so most victim groups at the
moment
are one of the easiest ways to give
yourself the status of empathetic
performative carer is to stand up for
victimized group
and yet it seems like nobody is choosing
to do it for this particular group
that if you manage to reframe the debate
you may be able to use the dynamic that
you're seeing online of people wanting
to film finger wave for a group and look
at how virtuous I am because of that if
you were able to change the way that the
conversation is framed you may actually
be able to utilize that desire in a
positive way yeah yeah yeah but it's I
guess you've got to redirect the stream
incredibly accurately and very carefully
uh
I think two things are going on and
they're not gonna let each other exist
one
uh is again when it was possible to walk
people through to the AHA uh it's often
very helpful to go through step by step
as I said start with plain vanilla gay
go through you know whatever the
different kinds of Kinks well what about
you know
why don't you give us the let's say that
there's someone that's still slightly
unconvinced and you've got your whatever
60 seconds or two minutes to walk
someone through from start to finish to
get to the aha moment what is it uh
again it's pieces of what we've said
already starting with a basic idea that
sexual orientation especially for men is
a hard-wired innate immutable they
didn't pick it or we didn't pick it and
it's not going to change
now so what are we there for you know
what means a civil right are we
therefore allowed to get married yeah
sure have sex and absolutely with anyone
we want well no they have to be
consenting anywhere we want well not
exactly public places there are
restrictions
okay and uh kinksters all right we're
now playing with the meaning and consent
because part of the hotness is that it's
non-consenting and so on but we have to
make sure for real is so it becomes a
little bit more complicated but we can
overcome that to make sure nobody's
getting hurt in a way that they don't
mean to be getting hurt
all right somebody who's turned on it's
a rare rare and fascinating sexual
interest uh pattern apotemophilia
these are people who feel like amputees
trapped in the body of a four-limbed
person
and they want and try and sometimes
succeed at having a limb Tech and often
if they're otherwise you know mentally
healthy and productive in society there
are indeed successful productive cases
of it
okay well if it's an adult control over
their own body if we don't do it they're
going to hurt themselves anyway but the
basic idea that it's built in they
didn't pick it it's easy to be
sympathetic for that uh for such a
person it's easy to uh think you know uh
there but by sheer luck you know go I I
could have been born without combination
too what what what do I wish society
would have would have done with me
and so we get to the more and more
stigmatized more and more yucky and more
and more uncomfortable and sooner or
later we end up with pedophiles where
now we're talking there are zero
potential Partners or situations we can
create
that would be safe for or in which there
can be a consenting partner so we kind
of go give range harder and harder until
we sooner or later or you know some real
real you know uh uh people with sexual
sadism again the fantasies would hurt
another person can't be done so now it's
a matter of fiction fantasy movies
written stories cartoons dolls uh
whatever
so once a person starts with a again
plain vanilla gay you're just born with
it well where's the line
between which one of these do we help
again we use consent and harm to another
person to decide which of these we can
act out and which ones have to stay in
fantasy but where in this line do are we
switching
from
yeah okay you're allowed to share
drawings versus not what
scientifically of course there is no
objective line
you know so far as Society is concerned
well if we're switching to Fantasy so
nobody's getting hurt anywhere on the
line all right so it's not out
sympathy because I could have been born
that way too wow look at that also works
for the whole the only thing left is
stigma
okay so we're okay with them for as long
as they're not stigmatized
wait a second
that isn't that how we got lgbtq and
your letters to begin with
and this is where my you know most
infamous tweet ever is is when I start
challenging people if it's not just
according to stigma
well then if we don't include P we're
Hypocrites what what's
you're saying we stigmatize it up to my
group and no further we stigmatize it
only when it becomes popular and no
further well that's not leadership
that's not rights principles that's just
this year's new version of what's
popular in this year's fashion and
but it's hypocritical to boot when it
now as I say and I know exactly how
that's taken people you know like taking
that little thing and saying oh my God a
pedophile apologist
it's just that this is entire I hesitate
to say rainbow but let's go you know
wide wide range according to stigma to
stigmatize not stigmatized and you know
I can understand why some of these uh
got stigmatized
uh but if
that's the only reason as long as they
keep it in fantasy what what all right
what's the objective other way to decide
that doesn't end up with us being
hypocrites
and by the way for the people acting out
on the ones that they can't act out on
you know if we take away the compromise
masturbation choice
again we're just making them more
desperate and congratulating ourselves
for stigmatizing it so much we drove it
underground where nobody can do anything
with it they're happy
uh Ed it uh
do you actually think that the P should
be an lgbtq
I use that phrase and I use it
purposefully to be provocative but the
question I always want to provoke and
what I wanted to provoke is what exactly
does it mean to be in there
popular well it Formed because it wasn't
popular is it a group of well didn't
have any choice just do the best you can
with what you have
again you know it's
um you know again openly gain myself and
very aware of the ancient history at
ancient of the history of it but
just shoving the stigma down to the next
group further down the stigmatization
list yeah I guess it feels a little bit
like uh people that use the if you're
feminist then you should be Pro male as
well as pro-female because feminism is
supposed to be for equality the question
around what is the LGBT group for is it
for including
uh non-typical sexual orientations into
a movement so that they feel less alone
uh if I I don't know what the broad
philosophy I don't even know if there is
one uh but if that was the case then I
know maybe there is a case to to talk
about that I can see why there would be
uh among many many reasons why people
would push back against that uh the
existing vestigial concern that some men
that are gay are secretly pedophiles
that are hiding it and that lumping P in
with g
would be a little bit close to home
people have a lot of different reasons
uh and again because now in the social
media age it's disproportionately the
number of people who who were just use
it for their own virtue signaling uh
they're also people who of course are
victims on child molestation
they don't know and don't really care if
they're you know perpetrator was
genuinely a pedophile or not doesn't
matter to such a person can I blame them
for having trouble separating I have
nothing but sympathy for uh for that
situa uh for the situation
uh
but I I think where a lot of people get
I think for a lot of people the the
conversation they're not having is that
uh to so many folk being in the lgbtq
alphabet translates necessarily to a
specific set of Rights
now they're often really thinking gay
rights can get married gays in the
military in the U.S you know I can get
my wedding cake made at whatever Baker I
want you know just basic civil rights
uh
but if that's it well then why do we
have B in there because they already had
half of those the only part that's
relevant to the bees are the parts that
are like the G's anyway well do the t's
belong in there because you know glb
doesn't need any surgery for any of this
doesn't matter
okay so the asexuals what rights is it
that the asexuals are going for
right so right so people just kind of
stick in add to the letters just to show
off how many letters they know
really it's just a list of you know look
how hip I am groups that are supposed to
uh that are supposed to be cool to be
either a part of or to recognize use of
but mostly people actually in their
heads are thinking basic civil rights
and are just adding on other letters
as I say just out of pedant just out of
being pedantic
uh to me it's a list of the actual
atypical sexualities who vary in a wide
and Broad way in their needs and their
features
for psalmids getting married for
asexuals that doesn't matter for
bisexuals it only half matters for
intersexuals it even depends on the kind
of intersexual you are for
cross-dressers it means I'm not exactly
sure
and for some people it means
can we not condemn them at a 10 at you
know every time we hear of them drive
them underground and instead make it
possible for them to get therapy instead
of passing mandatory reporting laws
right and so it's to me just this
constellation of different ways to be
sexually different Each of which has its
own
needs and features
I'm the one who sounds lgbtq and
everybody else is you're only allowed in
the group if you make me look good
ah
isn't that the popularity contest we
were supposed to be fighting against
people are only willing to fight for a
group after it looks good well I mean
you see certainly a part of that with
every month when pride month comes up
wherever you go when pride month comes
up and you see that
AMD
Technology Associates in America changes
their profile photo to a rainbow colored
flag but that the Middle East Division
doesn't change and the same thing goes
for Mercedes-Benz and BMW and Verizon
all of these different companies uh well
why what because it's a cheap virtue
signal to fight a war where the battle's
already been won
and where it's still to be done and
maybe this is New Territory maybe at
some point in the future this will but I
I do think that you know to try and
think of something like
applied here
there would be a way potentially to
utilize the performative empathy desire
that we have at the moment that's
prevalent on the internet to weaponize
that towards this group and to utilize
that so that people actually feel like
it is something that's virtuous to be
done but there is a hell of a lot of
stigma to get out of the way first so
going back go back to the actual
Behavior
I know from speaking to Diana Fleischman
that they're a hemophilia and what's the
is the one what's the other one that
isn't hemophilia what's before
hebophilia ephemophilia yep and is the
one before that
uh for adults teleophilia right okay
explain what those are and what are the
age brackets that are typical for uh
pedophiles to be attracted to yep uh it
sounds much more technical than that
than it needs to be uh but as you might
imagine when we do research in these
populations you know there are ranges
you know there are ones who are
attracted to very young kids
prepubescent kids you know up to about
age 10. how does people
uh
relatively rare
uh
10 to 15 percentage depending on how you
measure them it's not like Eve they they
check these off on a survey so usually
we kind of infer it from their sexual
offense pattern from uh from child
support on their computer or the most
important and the most objective way is
something called a phallometric test
uh it's essentially you know laboratory
Laboratory test we put a blood pressure
cuff on their penis and show them
stimuli of adults children male and
female and record what they react to
very sensitive very accurate test how do
you get showing
a research participant images of
children to judge the arousal response
past an Ethics board
ah
it's
I want to say more historical at this
point than anything else
uh the lab doing this work was founded
by Kurt freund who was doing it in the
1950s and 60s pre-dating ethics boards
and he was you know working with sex
offenders and demonstrated the accuracy
of the test and how it was uh superior
to the kind of clinical opinions that uh
that Physicians would uh uh were making
psychiatrists were making so of course
he continued doing research on and
continued publishing audit including
information about it's a diagnostic
accuracy uh so uh with that
that was sufficient for the ethics board
to get continue to you know continue to
do the uh to do the research also it was
completely transparent to the
correctional facilities most of the
people taking the test were sex
offenders already convicted and being
released to parole and probation
and then the test was part of a clinical
decision to decide you know is this a
genuine pedophile for whom we would use
sex drive reducing medications and the
kinds of therapies associated with
helping them deal with it
or was this an incest pattern somebody
with you know loose boundaries or
disinhibited or drug using and so those
are the kinds of ways to help this
person not commit an offense so it was a
clinical test in a correctional setting
and again transparent uh each of the
several ethics committees the police
themselves and so on uh and even
predated uh predated the uh the board uh
the board okay so under 10 around about
10 to 15 percent
yep are are definite pedophiles into
prepubescent kids
then if they're into pubes and kids
roughly ages 11 to 14 you know is the
next chunk of them and those are the
ones that we call hebophiles and in
doing research in order to try to figure
out is there a pattern here related to
be uh to age interest pattern you know
if we have now three points we can start
making a line if I have just pedophiles
and non-pedophiles I just have two
points but if I have three points now I
get to start seeing patterns even though
only a relatively few of them are
gold-plated solid pedophiles
uh then the group after that again not
much of a uh of a Corrections problem
but into 15 16 year olds and uh those
were called e fibo files uh and the age
of consent was I think it was 14 until
about 15 20 years ago so again it wasn't
illegal so it never really came came to
clinical attention then the sexually
attracted to regular everyday adults 17
and up uh in the lab where I did this
work that was tilio philia and then way
at the other end which really should
have become my next research that uh
research question gerontophilia
oh like Grandma and Grandpa
wow yep
have you got any idea
uh seems to be a handful of percent but
it's really really tough
it's tough to tell uh
it's tough to tell and
it's tough to tell even when it's
genuine I mean how much of it is sexual
attraction how much of it is you know
kind of gold digging mixed in
uh and how much of it especially for
young people is really
something that doesn't get talked about
and I wish I had the time to write about
is especially for young people uh if
they're into something different young
people are also into a broad range of
stuff just the color flesh is good
enough you know a group of pubes and
boys can met get erections and
masturbate in each other's company you
know without effort not a whiff of gay
about any of them it's just right when
Sex Drive is so high that end any any
devil do you
but as we mature and grow older it
really starts to have to be our thing in
order to work
and so I think that narrow Wing or as we
get older in our sex drive decreases it
has to be close to our favorite thing in
order to hit the bullseye right so I
think some people perceive the well I
could do anything you know and so an
older person or younger person at the
periphery when we're young and our sex
drive is high but when if we're in a
phase of life where it has to be our
favorite thing you know it it stops
being so I have to wonder uh how many of
these uh older younger couples are
really a younger person just who hasn't
yet
um well I mean narrowed in maybe we need
to start to take the young Playmate
models that they the 70 year old
billionaire with a little bit more of a
pinch of salt perhaps if they're one of
these
gerundophilias or whatever the the older
attractive older people think perhaps
they need their movement as well perhaps
there needs to be two G's I don't know
again they're adults you know do what
they like uh but it's rare in women
again for women the the the look of the
person is just one thread in a
complicated ball of wax so if the person
you know and confidence is often a big
part of it and the the
how much is money is up to question but
a lot of the you know uh confidence and
security that comes along with money is
often a big attractant
what is the common
uh
offending the gender of the the person
that's usually being uh imagined if it's
a male pedophile is it tending to still
be heterosexual
majority heterosexual but not as much of
a majority as you would guess
uh for offenders against adults
practically all against women
uh for offenders against children 60
percentish
you know so it's majority or female but
not
really the almost exclusive and
significantly over-represented in terms
of male to male attraction
correct
ah still some question
why
uh there is some truth too a person
who's a chick is sexually atypical
one-way is often sexually atypical in
other ways so if somebody's attracted to
Children you know they're closer to 50
50 than the you know
two three percent ninety seven percent
for regular adult gays
uh
another part of it is that there's just
less sexual differentiation in
prepubescent children
if your brain is attracted to you know a
childlike form change a haircut there's
not much morphological difference
between a seven-year-old boy and girl
but there's a huge morphological
difference you can see it you know
across the room between a 20 year old
you know young man young woman
uh so it's also easy to imagine that the
brain just doesn't care as much
if it's attracted to children as when
it's attracted to adults because the
shapes are as dimorphism yeah
interesting okay so this is a
conversation that I had about a year ago
and I I continued to try and have it in
the right company when I can
are child sex dolls ethical in your view
uh yes in the in that I've never heard
and I've been a part of many such
debates I've never heard anybody give me
any kind of an argument
that holds water it's either oh my God
that's going to cause pedophilia neither
stack of brain scans that says no it
won't
or they're just kind of grossed out
which is not an ethical concern
so what do the brain scans tell you
uh again the way that the brain is
different and the way that it formed
this isn't anything a person chose it's
not a person anything a person can read
Choose Or roll the dice again these are
not areas or volumes of the brain that
change with exercise or you know
dyslexia skills uh these are as I say
like in every meaningful way is like a
sexual orientation it's just kind of
built in born with it and all we can do
is accommodate it
so if we have something that might help
no good evidence that it'll hurt
and the only arguments anybody can give
is their emotional discomfort
well if emotional discomfort were a good
enough reason we'd be back to the
anti-gay days do you have any evidence
to say that it's not a gateway drug
um
evidence to say that it's not
that's not
a question science can answer
uh it's called proving the null
hypothesis
in science we start with these things
are not related until somebody shows
that they are it's not possible to prove
that things are not related but you
would be able to because it's always
possible that somebody later will
produce evidence that there is so as I
said let's say that you introduced a
bunch of child sex dolls into a
non-offending group of pedophiles and
you then saw a greater increase in the
number of real the amount of real world
harm that went on because of the
introduction of them
there's a
nobody's ever seen that kind of pattern
but I'm not sure
any jurisdiction yet has had a situation
where they weren't available all of a
sudden there was whatever legal
precedent now they are available so all
of a sudden there are ten thousand of
them
and we can look for an uptick the
but there's never been that kind of
natural experiment
the
predominant the only offense which
happens in any
frequency that that co-occurs in any
frequency is uh child pornography use
downloading hoarding
uh when somebody uh there are people who
just you know through internet stings
that's the extent of their crime you
know usually there's a very very
thorough investigation of you know any
children in that guy's environment
and rarely do they find anybody who was
uh uh uh physically or one-on-one
interfered with that that relatively
rare
the other way around happens with some
uh co-occurrence when an actual Hands-On
offense comes to light and then they go
through the guy's computers then as I
said more often a couple of percent of
the time a substantial chunk of those
they will find a child born
so if we were gonna guess
our best educated guess would be a
similar
would be a similar pattern that it would
be elevated somebody willing to break a
law is all also going to be willing to
break a smaller law if I can call it a
child defense that but to do the
relatively innocuous things before they
go the distance yes but of the ones who
write find I'll say A pro-social you
know fantasies written stuff fiction
whatever somebody who finds an
inoffensive way of doing it nobody's
found uh connection going the other way
that's interesting to think about
the fact that affection a story which is
written or I guess illustrations as well
perhaps is a way drawings yes drawings
would be a way to
I mean it's a difficult question to work
out should there be a an ethical no
externality way
to help people in this community
suffer less whilst minimizing real world
harm
that's a that's one of the most
difficult questions ethically that I can
think of
yup
it doesn't fit in a tweet it does not
fit in a tweet no a 260 characters is
not long enough for that but it's a
fascinating consideration that okay do
you want people to suffer unnecessarily
and as I say It's the final domino in
the series because the entire sexual
again I'll use the word spectrum of
everybody's whatever they're into all of
the Kinks this is the hardest one if we
can unravel this one all the others
are I don't know I've deluded as the
right word but uh
simpler less fraught version of this
toughest one
let's delve into the spiciest one then
what about people who feel like they're
living in the wrong body what's going on
yeah
never in my life I shouldn't say that
the biggest thing that surprises me by
by the trans controversies is how fast
they've taken over
I mean we've seen other situations in
healthcare and medical health care where
the people who are supposed to be in
charge and making sure things stick to
the evidence there have been slips in
the past multiple personalities you know
the satanic Panic the
recovered memories uh and even Physical
Medicine stents meshes uh feeding babies
formula instead of uh mothers nursing
their children I mean medicine has
for some situations made this mistake
before
I was
surprised alerted
shocked you know to see one happen you
know in I want to say that I was
surprised to see what happened you know
in my own field but yeah it sucks we
have so many so controversial issues you
know it's always a matter of time
uh but the thing that surprised me is
that uh unlike you know breastfeeding
and recovered memories and so on how
fast this one pretty literally went
viral
that's the thing that shocked me how
quickly it's uh it's moved uh people uh
the particular phrase uh being born uh
in uh in the wrong body in a perfectly
reasonable here and there as a as a
metaphor
but people are taking metaphors as
literal truths people are taking
subjective evidence and making decisions
on it that we normally would preserve
for the most solid and objective
evidence you know we're sending into
surgery you know to operate and remove
healthy tissue
but giving it you know the same bar of
evidence that we would use for taking
out a tumor you know it it's uh all of
which is on top of even though everybody
you know keeps saying oh you know you
need mental health professionals and you
need a robust diagnosis
nobody knows how to do that
we can't predict which of these kids if
any or of What proportion will benefit
versus not
so we have the least knowledge the least
outcomes and the least ability to
correctly pick out which one in these
hundred will benefit and we're applying
the most dramatic interventions
available to us
uh
uh no I'm not an ideologue I mean it's I
often have been one of the advocates for
transition for adults who have lived
part of their life know what they're
sacrificing
but we had much more solid evidence for
them than for children
but we're treating child cases as if we
had the level of evidence and the
objective you know reliable indications
that we just don't have if in the future
we do great if we come up with a good
way to pick out the correct one and not
misdiagnose the other 99 great
but we're not there yet we're operating
on the wrong ones I'm gonna guess as
well that
because this has had such rapid takeoff
especially when it comes to
transitioning children we have
very little if basically no evidence to
look at what the outcomes are like long
term for children who go through gender
reassignment surgery or who take hormone
blockers to stop themselves going
through puberty or to limit puberty once
it begins okay what are the life
outcomes in terms of satisfaction like
for these children when they become
adults and you know this is a political
football that is easy to be kicked
around by whichever side you know the
right will happily roll out somebody
that wants to de-transition and say that
they should have gone through a ton more
consent and then the left will roll out
some young 14 year olds that took their
life because they felt like they weren't
whatever and you just go okay I want to
try and cut through some of the [ __ ]
here
um I guess that looking at what happens
over longer term studies would be one
way to do that take a longitudinal study
of it but
given that we don't allow children to
vote Smoke Drink have sex drive a car in
the UK can't buy an energy drink until
you're 16 years old you can't buy a Red
Bull until you're 16. you can't have sex
but you can change your gender
like that that to me it there is a risk
that you're running in trying to find
out whether this is right or not in
allowing a big swath of children to go
through something which could
potentially damage them but on the other
side of that what if this turned out to
be like the the pedophile debate that
we're having earlier on and it's oh well
maybe the outcomes in this are
absolutely great I don't think that
that's going to be the case I think that
I would be unbelievably surprised if it
was
I have no idea
well okay let's start off have you got
any idea what is happening in the brains
of people who are transgender is is
there anything
that's a signature which is going on are
there any common threads
yes and no
the
studies of the brain in trans
populations the study of the brain
sexuality have found homosexuality is in
the brain gender identity is not
but very many trans people are also
homosexual relative to their birth sex
so depending on who's in your study
you'll get different confusing mixes
because the stuff in the brain that's
there because of homosexuality is easy
to mistake for stuff in the brain for
transsexuality but when you pile it all
together
homosexuality is in the brain both male
and female gender identity is not but
some of the studies compared homosexual
transsexuals with heterosexual CIS
people and said seed transsexuality in
the brain when no what they found was
homosexuality in the brain
so that's the
as I say people will cite whichever part
whichever studies line up with their
with their belief system uh
now there are other things in the brain
there are other uh
that's the part that's relevant for
children
adults show a completely different
pattern when I say adults I mean people
who didn't really start becoming gender
dysphoric until adulthood they knew they
were different they had you know some
they were a little bit odd sometimes
especially socially when they were young
but basically heterosexual usually
married often almost always male uh had
a wife has kids and then in their 30s or
40s to sud you know before it's too late
foreign
Jenner kind of a profile would never
have picked the person out of a crowd
not a whiff of femininity about them
until
that get to a point in life where you
know before it's too late
I gotta try this
uh completely different pattern
completely different pattern from the
highly effeminate or tomboyish ones and
kids where they stick out like a sore
thumb and when they came out as gay you
go surprise surprise
that adult onset type also seems to have
a uh brain signature to it but unrelated
to homo to sexual orientation unrelated
to homosexuality it's related to a
pattern unto itself and related to a
paraphilia
the trans Community hate hate hate this
idea because it makes that kind of trans
person seem less genuine
when the evidence doesn't say that the
evidence actually is much stronger for
their transition than the kids but it's
called Auto gynophilia these are kind of
like
men who are not just into searching for
the brain looking for women in the
environment it wants to project signals
of that femininity to the environment
it's like they're attracted to The Woman
Within
and that motivates a large chunk of
cross-dressers not the you know drag
queen knee type of the more you know
it's part of their sex thing for uh
people with other atypical sexualities
again it will often have a cross-dressy
or fetishy element to it and for some
people you know it's strong enough and
concrete enough that they actually live
perfectly healthy
perfectly healthy lives is female now
fetish is called autogenophilia Dirty
word in large chunks of the trans
community and a popular idea in other
chunks take your pick
okay so they also seem to be different
to the brain but because of the
paraphilia rather than because of the
sexual orientation and I think because
they're mostly the activists they want
to treat the children the way they wish
they were treated when they were that
age even though these are unrelated
phenomena they have nothing to do with
each other so the brain is in there
but uh it's not in there in the uh you
have a trans brain that's that's not it
it's you have a gay brain and for some
people it's kind of like you're so gay
you really might be happy you're living
as the other sex and for some people
it's yup you're really Auto gynophilic
you might be someone I got aragonophilic
you might actually be happier living as
the other sex so unrelated motivations
they just
when they describe their subjective
experience they use the same words like
the doctor the patient comes in Duck I
have a headache stress headache head
injury migraine they will all say
headache their descriptions will sound
the same but the best thing for these
people are completely unrelated to each
other
I have a friend who is trans and we
threatened slash encouraged her to go to
a strip club at some point and the fear
in her eyes
are at the potential of having to see a
lady potentially naked in front of her
was huge is that your friend was trans
which way so male to female still with
the male bits okay uh but just did not
want to see a vagina
at all
that seems like
the I don't know what that is that seems
like the opposite of what okay literally
feminine or yes yeah very very much so
yeah yeah that that I see that pattern
why what's going on there
foreign
into people like that
patients friends randoms
uh
it's
like
a kind of gay stick but
dialed up
and again a lot of my gay friends you
know breasts are one thing but the
vagina is just icky
yeah okay I know what you mean what
about the correlation between the trans
community and autism
fascinating
uh
I think this is another one of those Z
producing both
X and Y I think the thing in the brain
that's
atypical it the part of the brain that
uh uh uh manifests uh social relatedness
mirror neurons are natural herd
instincts something unusual with as I
say the social instincts which include
the sexual instincts and with that a bit
off you know that gives us autism can
also give us borderline personality
disorder which is again very extreme
hyper-emotional kinds of relationships
and you know certain kinds of uh
fetishes and auto gynophilia which again
is just a neurologically based social
set of instincts so I think of that
massive tissue didn't develop in the
usual way these things start correlating
because they're all related to that same
clump of social neuroanatomy what did
you mean when you said that gender
identity is not in the brain
if autism is something which is in the
brain am I being thick here
ah
it no autism is in the brain and it's
Auto gynophilia the sexual interest
pattern yes that's in the brain okay but
having that sexual interest pattern and
just using it as masturbation fantasy
living a perfectly happy life versus I
have it and want to change my body okay
so it seems to me correct me if I'm
wrong it sounds to me a little bit like
your proposed stance when it comes to
people that are trans is that it is uh
an overshooting of a continuation of
sexual orientation like just way way way
Beyond where we see gay or lesbian at
the moment is that right yes right
sometimes we'll even joke a joke about
it remember the Kinsey scale zero to six
now and then you'll meet somebody who's
an 11. right okay
that's an interesting way to frame it
um okay so autism so the difference
between hit and Homo is very big but the
difference between CIS homo and trans
homo is very slight
so we can detect these differences but
we can't distinguish these two from each
other maybe in the future we will but
right now
and this is why a lot of my gay friends
Douglas Murray Andrew Doyle uh both of
them have concerns around the trans
movement being rehabilitated homophobia
and uh I think it's Andrew that uses
this example of a guy who is a father
and he had a son that was super
effeminate and wanted to transition and
wanted to become a girl and then they I
don't know whether they went through
surgery or not but they certainly at
least renamed this boy into a girl and
they interviewed the father afterward
and he said you know what it is I'm just
really happy that I don't have to see my
little boy mincing around the garden
anymore
and you go oh that that's that's just
homophobia like that's you just really
didn't want a gay son and for you it's
easier to believe that you've got a
trans daughter
than a gay son
I hear that story a lot again I don't
want to say get it I have no idea what
proportion of cases that represents but
I hear that story in that kind of story
over and over again that there's some
secondary reason or there's some
tangential motivation that makes this
a path of least resistance
rather than the best among the options
is it India or some Arab country that's
got the highest rate of trans Iran Iran
yeah because you're not allowed to be
gay but you can be trans so this is
that's like a a government mandated
bureaucratic version of of that okay
well I mean that the fact that you see
it as a almost like a single
continuation like a single Continuum
sorry from
um trans female to trans male with
everything in between and it's just
sexual orientation sexual orientation
takes you so far the degree of aversion
to the other sex is so great that you
sometimes want to almost re you do want
to repurpose your own body in order to
fit the way that you see the world
fascinating
uh and it goes together with several of
the other fetishes the paraphilias uh we
often think of these them as having you
know three dimensions you know attracted
to male versus female
attracted to Old versus Young
and attracted to you know Personnel in
the environment versus being that person
and so we also get people you know if
they're attracted to Young the
pedophiles we also get you know the age
play fetishists you know the diaper
fetishes they want to be the child
uh they're a child that's turned inward
so we have as I say so you can be
attracted to women in the world you can
be attracted to
The woman Inside you could be attracted
to children in the world you can be
attracted to the
child inside so as I say and my guess
Fantasy on my part is that this is a
mirror neuron thing this is part of our
you know social
neuroanatomy that's just
tweaked or twerked or not quite right
and it has these various various side
effects
uh now of course the idea of you know
projecting sexual receptivity well that
you know long predates our species
so the cross wiring between you know
what sexual Clues to give off and what
sexual Clues to be on the lookout for
these are parallel nerve fibers it's not
hard to you know if they didn't
myelinate properly if they didn't
densify properly if there were just too
few of them
they work like a it's like a hologram if
you take out half a hologram you don't
get half of a picture you get the whole
picture but a bit blurry
that's how the brain works so if you
just are missing a few of the neurons
you know if it's a lower density you
know these can't distinguish as clearly
what I'm supposed to be projecting
versus what I'm supposed to be on the
lookout for and we kind of get these
and that's why if you're into one sexual
atypicality you may be into several
others at the at the same time so as I
say these these interests kind of Clump
somebody who's attracted to amputees
stump fetishists they're called and then
the one with a long funny name
apotemophilia they want to be the
amputee
so interesting I don't know why
everybody isn't a sex researcher it's I
I feel like I should have been in a
different life okay so what about the
relationship between the trans community
and suicide because this a lot of the
time is seems to be one of the uh
propositions that's put forward about
why transitioning is so important uh
that it's really really
what can I say out loud
unfortunate is to understate it uh how
the situation and the myth of the
situation and this is another one where
the myth of that situation can easily be
making the problem worse
nobody was talking about you know trans
and suicide until 2018 and it started
with a particular paper first author's
name was to me
survey which claimed you know
headlines all over you know large
proportion 40 percent you know of these
kids you know uh attempt suicide or uh
uh had ideas about suicidality oh my God
we have a correlation and everybody was
after the causality races we have a
correlation
transphobia is causing these people that
these kids to commit suicide
not what the paper said in fact
practically the reverse of what the
paper said and the paper itself and then
the headlines describing the paper
getting it backwards
the biggest big big biggest mistake
people are making is that they are
confusing suicide to be a synonym for
suicidality
again to the public those are synonyms
to an expert these are different
phenomena
suicide very very rare mostly male
mostly middle age mostly impulsive and
mostly with lethal means in a person
with a sincere intent to die
suicidality is the ideation the threats
the calls for help it represents an
indication of distress not an intent to
die
mostly female mostly adolescent mostly
uses a uh uh uh I don't want to say
insincere they are sincere cries for
help but what they need is attention and
therapy it's not an intent to die less
lethal
rarely lethal at all
uh
lethality is elevated I mean it's higher
than Baseline but it's not the 40 of
these kids are going to kill themselves
which is the you know emotional
political manipulation of it that's not
true this is as I say genuine
psychological distress for which they
need therapy
unfortunately what it's being used as is
essentially give me what I want or I'll
kill myself oh my God that makes up
whatever they were asking for a medical
necessity uh no when a kid has a tantrum
giving them the lollipop will keep him
quiet for a minute but that's not good
parenting
it's we need to deal with the Tantrums
now the 40ish that's not a trans thing
glbt in general it is an adolescent
stress thing adolescence with any mental
health problem in the book roughly 40
percent of you ask them sometime in
their life will have had some suicidal
ideation I don't want to say it's normal
again it's a cause for therapy it's not
they're on their way to death if we
don't do anything
also the idea strikes me as a bit weird
that you know people are saying you know
it's five six seven percent of the
population 40 of them are suicidal and
no one ever noticed until five years ago
as I said the whole story is a bit crazy
uh anyway uh so the story is about
suicidality kids in genuine distress
but they keep saying you know when they
put out a survey saying oh my God it's
the kids who transition not as
distressed
and as I say we're going from the
correlation to causality races
all of the clinical criteria you know
you need a robust psychological
assessment and if a person with you know
profound mental health issues you have
to take care of those uh those first so
those kids wouldn't be getting
transition Services they're getting
filtered out by the gatekeeping system
so what happens when I take a survey of
everybody
I get all of the people some of whom
were rejected because they weren't
healthy enough
and I get the ones who transitioned
from who the poorest functioning ones
were filtered out so when I take a
survey the ones who transitioned have
hired have higher Mental Health
not because transition gave them higher
Mental Health
it's that the ones with better mental
health were allowed to transition in the
first place they were pre-selected you
had this pre-selected group that's why
you can't go from correlation to
causation that's why it seems like it's
lower suicidality and so on even though
transition is not the common link the
common link is General mental health
peer functioning and family functioning
so the association the association as I
say with suicidality and trans
adolescence there's a correlation but
not a causal one this is an indication
of distress indicating people
in genuine as I say who needs
Psychotherapy the studies which which
suggest Improvement these kids weren't
getting just hormones they were getting
therapy at the same time
we have no way of knowing you know their
mental health improved because of the
pills or shots or the mental health
improved because they were getting
mental health treatment
we can't guarantee that that was the
source of the Improvement but we sure
should figure that out before we start
removing healthy tissue
I suppose if the concerns of people on
the internet about
poorly researched transitioning for
children occurring quickly
over the next few years you will end up
with a little bit more of a control for
this because you're not going to have
children that are being screened as
thoroughly this gatekeeping does seem to
be slipping away unless I'm reading the
wrong things on the internet which I
almost certainly probably am my point
being that you're going to be able to
control at least a little bit more for
how much mental health robustness the
individual has and also the amount of
therapy that they go through if the
rumors about their transgender kids with
you you walk in you give them 100 Grand
and they go out of there with a
vaginoplasty or whatever uh if that's
the case then you would have the
opportunity to study this more would
that be right to say
uh
the way things seem to be going
internationally I I I don't think it's
quite that pattern uh Europe has already
figured this out uh uh Finland Sweden
the UK uh France Spain is now grappling
with it they've now pretty much put an
end to the social transition on demand
and one after another their health care
departments are saying you know hormones
and blockers only as part of a
registered uh uh experiment this is no
longer you know treatment uh of course
uh
as a matter of course so Europe has
already put a stop to it and now any
liberalization of that gatekeeping will
be one experiment at a time which is
where we were 10 years ago before all
this went crazy
uh
in the US the customer knows best
these clinics aren't recording outcomes
because they already keep claiming lots
of success and nobody wants to document
the lack of success so if a patient goes
away they don't want to go find that
patient and find out that it was a
passion to regretted it
sure enough the insurance companies and
so on and so on and now you know the
political activists and all of the
people whose faces are on the line you
know and We're Off to the Races
so with the political and financial
pressures so enormous in the U.S
it's hard for me to imagine a real world
scenario in which an honest attempt to
gather a matched control group will
exist there are going to be my patients
who are still here which are whatever
percentage happy ones and then the who
knows what proportion we will never find
out and they don't want to find out lost
to follow up we're not going to call
them regreters they just stopped coming
back for their shots
well so I I think that what you're
seeing is perhaps yet another
externality of what happens where they
paid for medical system with the
incentives aligned like you've got in
America you know it's
the only country in the world I think
except for Australia where drug
companies are allowed to advertise on
television and for someone that lived
the first 30 years of his life in the UK
coming out and hearing ask your doctor
about at the end of an advert is so
bizarre like what do you ask my doctor
about this thing I tell him what's wrong
and he tells me what I'm so it's not I
don't go and record it's like a barber
shop I don't get over a pick and mix I'm
going to go and say oh yeah I've heard
about this particular drug I really
think that I should take it so yeah I
think that
part of it I almost wanted to run it
it's like I I want to do mock
commercials in American Medical system
where the patient knows best yep
yeah it's very bizarre very very very
bizarre and um I I kind of get this
sense
one of the next Battlegrounds that I
could see if I was to make a little bit
of a prediction I would think that
circumcision
is going to be something which will
become a more of a Hot Topic over the
next few years
um in the UK circumcision outside of the
Jewish Community is basically not a
thing in the U.S
non-circumcision is basically not a
thing
like way way and I tweeted about it the
other day because Bill Maher uh had
posted about it on his podcast it just
like I like some of brill's stuff but
this was such a brainlet take it was
completely insane and uh
I tweeted about it and a bunch of people
came up in the replies and it seems like
there's a big Financial incentive there
as well like a huge financial incentive
for procedures circumcision procedures
to go ahead I was like who's making
money off tiny little foreskins but
apparently there is a market for
everything and that's another one of
them so yeah when the incentives get
aligned in this way yeah all manner of
weird
Oddities and strange externalities come
out on the other side that's I I would
not be at all surprised if that uh
circumcision is in the distance
uh or we're at the end of circumcision
no wait a second let me work on this
part there's a better I I haven't found
it yet but there's a better joke
uh the tip of the end the end of the tip
uh
but for the American system
that question hasn't been asked nearly
in the way that I think it should not
circumcision but uh
it's even though
within the US they keep saying all the
American Medical associations yada yada
yada
they're missing the key word the key
word is all the American Medical
associations which are now pretty
isolated relative to the rest of the
world
that's the question in the rest of the
world with socialized medicine you know
there's a committee deciding this and
deciding where the money goes and what
you know meets what level of criteria
in the U.S they we depend on you know
these professions to self-regulate
well they dropped the ball on this one
really at and being perfectly explicit
not for the children's interests
for their own Guild interests
doctors don't want the government
telling doctors what to do
period
at the moment it happens to be about
trans children
but the medical establishment is not
protecting or doing anything but trans
children they're just
keeping there from there being the
beginnings of a slippery slope of the
government telling doctors what to do
that's what all of these medical
associations are agreeing on this just
happens to be the issue of it
this just happens to be the the issue
over which over which they're saying it
none of them have engaged in any of the
kind of you know systematic scientific
review Europe has
but the U.S has not you know their
policies
are just don't cite the research or
everybody keeps saying decision has to
be made by a mental health professional
have you noticed that the mental health
professionals don't have a treatment
it all of this is left up to to
guesswork Really uh and again they've
said explicitly when wpath removed there
are no more age minimums took all of
them all of them out uh age minimums
were whichever kind of uh transition
zero citations cited for justification
but with the person in charge of the
chapter said was they didn't doctors
getting sued
in case they
gave whatever transition to a service to
a kid under that age
I'm sorry but isn't that what standards
are for
eign
so it's a document that essentially says
use clinical judgment and you shouldn't
be held responsible for the uh for the
outcomes of your decisions
if the medical systems the medical
establishment has not been able to see
through to the science on this
what can what
should
right so to me it's uh
if you can't figure this one out if you
can't be trusted with this what can you
be trusted with and so it's time for the
us as I say to do with the rest of the
world has done
and take out all the middle people and
it's not like the US has great health
care outcomes to be proud of
Dr James Carter ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the stuff that
you do online and keep up to date with
you where should they go
uh that's a good question usually
Twitter or uh jameskenter.org
James I appreciate you thank you for the
day pleasure is mine what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace